trois morceaux en titane d'un moteur
d'airbus voici ce que l'aviation civile
a retrouvé dans des bois situé entre
l'yonne et la côte d'or
ce n'est qu'une toute petite partie de
la pièce tombée en vol d'un avion mais
des débris encourageante pour les
enquêteurs
on a donc un moteur relativement récent
qui est une défaillance assez importante
et l'idée c'est de retrouver ces pièces
parce que sans retrouver l'initiation
delà de la rupture
on pourra pas l'expliquer l'idée c'est
de coûts d'expliquer la rupture pour
résoudre le problème et qui est pas un
événement similaire qui arrive à nouveau
coup cette battue est une première en
france depuis ce matin 200 hectares de
bois sont ratissés ici en juillet
dernier un airbus a perdu un retour de
moteurs une pièce comme celle-ci 70 cm
de diamètre qui aurait explosé lors de
sa chute
les enquêteurs concentrent leurs
recherches sur un périmètre précis en
bordeaux sur cette carte là même où
trois premiers morceaux donc été
retrouvé malgré la pluie et des
conditions difficiles de quoi donner
espoir aux bénévoles
on cherche partout en l'air sous l'effet
en utilise le bâton pour regarder et on
est bien serré donc normalement on
devrait quadrillé tout à forest pourquoi
pas rechercher une pièce qui est
primordial qui évitera peut-être 2 2
que des gens que tu en avion les
recherches doivent durer encore deux
jours elles vont se concentrer sur la
zone où les premiers débris du moteur de
l'airbus ont été retrouvés